[Music]
what
hello and thank you once again for
joining us here on this program I'd like
to know it is always an honor and a
blessing for us to share the questions
that you have uh sent to us and
providing the answers to those questions
we want want to remind you to send your
questions and your inquiries to
TVs
tv.org and you can see that address in
your screen and with that said you can
rest assured that by the grace of God we
will respect respond to that question uh
sometimes we have more than we can
handle or we can answer uh right away so
have patience but we're getting to your
questions that is a promise to you it is
always a blessing and a privilege for me
to start or have this program with
Pastor Steven bour Pastor Steven bore
welcome once again to this program it is
always a joy to have you here with us
well it's always a pleasure to be here
uh you know presidential Duties are no
fun but this is fun yes really uh doing
research and answering people's
questions
and hearing the compliments that people
out there give concerning this program
uh tells me that it really makes a
difference in people's lives so I'm
thankful to be here amen Pastor thank
you it is true what you just said that
it is a blessing to see that the program
is reaching the hearts reaching people
that are watching and that uh we can you
know contribute in a little way to their
spiritual growth by answering the
questions they have so Pastor Bor if you
don't mind starting with a word of
prayer as we enter into the questions
for today
okay Father in Heaven uh as we open your
word now we plead for the presence of
your Holy Spirit The Same Spirit that
inspired your word because only he is
able to explain it to us amen so we ask
that you'll be present with us through
the ministry of your spirit uh help us
to answer the questions clearly amen and
uh in harmony with your word and we
thank you for the promise of your
presence we claim that promise in Jesus
name amen amen amen amen okay we have
the first question coming to us from uh
Bernard he's from Magalia California
this is north of Sacramento thank you
for sending the the information where
you live Bernard and we hope that
questions can be answered all right he
says uh he says first of all I love this
program it has been a real blessing to
me we're very thankful that is the case
and he says I'd like to know why Jesus
used the different methods to heal the
Blind and he enlists four methods that
he has found the first one is how Jesus
do found in John 9 1-14 Jesus gave sight
to a blind man by spitting on the ground
making clay and putting the clay on his
eyes that's the first example then in
Matthew 9:
27-31 we have the example of Jesus
giving sight to two Blind Men by
touching their eyes then we have third
example found in Luke 18
35-43 where Jesus gave sight to a blind
man by speaking to him and in Mark 8:22
to 26 here Jesus heal a blind man in
stages making a second attempt to
complete the healing so the question is
why did Jesus use different methods to
heal the blind p word any insight into
this question interesting thoughts you
know I have not been been able to
determine the reason why there's
different methods of healing uh the one
that's particularly perplexing is the
one where uh he healed one blind man and
he saw that he saw it says he saw men
that move like trees yes you know I've
heard different explanations but none of
the explanations have really been
satisfactory the ones that I've heard uh
with regards to the other you know um
the method of spitting the method of
touching the eyes speaking the person to
to be healed I haven't found any
significance to the method that was used
uh I think that the focus is on
particularly on the healing itself um
however uh everything that Jesus did had
a reason I'm sure there's a there's a
variation of Reason uh but uh I haven't
been able to detect it it may be a
question that we need to uh spend a more
time to research and see you know what
is the purpose of those different type
of methods I mean we could see that in
certain for example the first example
that he mentions that Christ mentioned
you know by spit on the ground and
making clay and putting the clay on his
eyes then he sends the man to he gives a
command go and wash yourself in that you
know in the in the pond by Silo you know
and so he may be you know that he wanted
that man to experience what it means to
obey you know in faith and and you know
maybe the experience was to encourage
that man to um to Believe In Christ more
so in the in the command of Christ than
the actual uh element of you know
miraculous power in the second I don't
know there might be other reasons we're
not exactly sure like you mentioned I
think that we need to study perhaps more
but um I don't know it just it seems to
me that these methods or these
experiences that God uses had a reason
that we need to probably dig in a little
little deeper we looked into that I
suppose I think it would be a good idea
to maybe write uh to Bernard Bernard's
email yes to find out if he has done
some research into it and whether he has
found the reason for the differences yes
it's an interesting thought I know and
the Lord this is the thing you know the
Lord can't provide us with Insight or
with different ways of seeing this is
why the interpretation of the word of
God I mean is the Lord that inspires the
interprets itself and uh we ourselves
need to learn to maybe study and find
out but it's a good question we're going
to continue to study more about it maybe
we can get it back to him later all
right so um let's go to the next
question and this question is
uh let's see the question is
this home invasion what to do in
situations like home invasion Country
property
Invasion and uh anyone that can look on
a Google map and see which country
properties contain
Gardens that's a I guess a third the
third question if I'm not exactly sure
if that's a question or more like a
statement of of what should be done and
finally is should a 7day Adventist own a
gun W this is an interesting thing so
four things he has questions about home
invasion Country property Invasion the
fact that anybody can look in a Google
map and see which country properties
contain Gardens and should a stist own a
gun maybe you know is in regards to
self-defense what is you know the ansers
pastor what you think we can give this
friend of ours answers to this well uh I
think that the first thing that we need
to remember is that God is our protector
mhm you know I'm not sure that we should
take a gun into our hands and shoot
shoot a home
Invader because if the home Invader
hasn't given his life to Christ and uh
would later give his life to
Christ then you're taking that person's
life so you need so we need to trust the
Lord and that doesn't mean that there
never will be a case when uh somebody
invades the home or somebody invades the
property uh but you know we need to
trust the Lord that the Lord will do his
work and he will protect uh both people
and property mhm and I I fear that maybe
our friend has concerns of privacy you
know uh people finding out if he has
Gardens or not in his house I mean maybe
he's thinking ahead of time you know in
the later time of travel I've heard a
lot of people you know worried about you
know people are going to come and steal
your fruits and your vegetables that
kind of thing you know so maybe there's
that concern and and perhaps it's a
concern out of you know worry that he
won't provide it for his family or that
you know but like you said pastor you
know we need to have trust in the Lord
ultimately he is the one that that can
sustain and protect and he mentions his
word you know he can encamp around those
that fear and and love him you know so
the angel of God can be around us
protect us from all evil uh I think that
we need to be careful not to follow into
this you know ahead of time worry about
what whether or not you know people can
see in the Google Maps or see you know
satellites uh whether or not what we
have as a matter of fact the Bible
speaks that we should be open letters to
the world you know so in a sense we
should not necessarily uh have to should
be afraid of being living a life and if
we have a garden and we have a you know
a we have a property in the country uh
we need to do our best to take care of
it but at the end of the day if the Lord
is is with us who is against us number
one number two um this aspect of you
know home invasion country Invasion um
it's a fear that can happen as you
mentioned but I remember the story in
the
Bible of uh Jacob he dig you know he had
to back those days he had to dig Wells
to provide water for his family for his
cattle for his whole thing you know and
he did a well and they came and took
that well away from him and he didn't
fight for for it he just moved away and
he did another one and again they came
and they took that you know well away
and he got to go several times digging
wells until he finally dig one that was
so deep you know that uh it was uh the
one that was for him when nobody finally
stopped bothering him now I'm not saying
necessarily that we're going to have to
let you know properties go in a sense
but you know I believe that we should
not feel that we need to be the ones
that need to be our arm you know to you
know to our teeth and protect our
property at all costs that is not a
Biblical um lesson at all you know we
are to um to buy wisely you know if
you're going to buy a property make sure
you buy in a place where it's you know
the neighbors you get to know the
neighborhood you need to know the people
but if you buy houses in a places where
there's a lot of invasion what not you
know it's kind of you put yourself in a
situ ation that is going to be against
you know uh you so I think you have to
be wise but ultimately we should not
feel that like we need to defend our
property as as as wisely you said if
that person comes into your place and
try to bra or take away from you you
know the Lord paid a price an infinite
price for that soul and we are to you
know find a way to love that person even
if that person takes even even what's
ours you know so I think this it's more
of that the religion of Jesus mhm is uh
is sometimes many mer very difficult yes
and we don't really understand it but we
need to do what he says yeah in Matthew
Chapter 5 and verse um 38
MH you have heard that it was said an ey
for an ey and a tooth for a tooth well
that's the way most people live right
you hit me I hit you back right yeah but
I tell you do not resist an evil person
but whoever slaps you on your right
cheek turn the other to him also yeah
now what person ever if they slap you on
the cheek you say oh slap me on the
other one you know uh you might consider
this hyperbole but I think Jesus is
trying to make a point here yes and then
if uh if anyone wants to sue you MH and
take away your tunic
sue him back no that's not what it says
let him have your cloak also mhm so you
you want my tunic oh don't you want my
coat too you know that that's that's not
the world the way the world operates
absolutely and then uh he continues
saying and whoever compels you to go one
mile go with him
too give to him who asks you and from
him who wants to borrow from you do not
turn away mhm the the religion of Christ
is very
demanding I mean it's not the regular
way of human thinking you know um it's a
religion of
giving even at our own expense amen and
I think that's the thing you know what
really motivates us to be you know
concerned about these things is it that
we feel that God cannot protect us you
know I think that uh if we don't have
the faith that God can protect us
and he can sustain even our own life
we're going to be fighting you know for
our things for our properties and that
kind of thing but I believe if the Lord
puts in our heart a love for people um
you know there will be no need for us to
worry about these things I think God
will provide a way for us to provide to
others and give to others if they come
and ask for food we'll give them food
and so and then the last question you
know about owning a gun what could we
say about that Pastor I know this is a a
very interesting thing you know that in
the majority of countries outside the
the I would say the Protestant countries
you know like likeit States and other
countries that are Protestant where
owning a gun is is actually one of the
rights if you will of of of the
Constitution many of the countries you
can't really have a gun I mean it's just
simple as that you know it's illegal to
own a gun and so for a lot of entist
that outside the North America or the
countries that are more um you know
Protestant in in in con stitution where
you know they allowed you to have guns
it's something that is not even thought
of you know simply you just don't have a
gun you know it's just legal um but in
countries such as this that is legal um
do you I mean he's asking should we own
guns the question well I don't I don't
think that it's a sin to own a
gun uh the the question is how are you
going to use the gun you know some
people uh purchase a gun for
recreational purposes
just to I know that I worked with a
departmental guy uh who when we worked
in the Texico conference and he had uh
357 Magnum as well as other weapons yeah
and on the way from Amarillo to
Albuquerque uh he would take all of
these gallon jugs that were he filled
them with water and then we would stop
in a certain place and uh he would uh
shoot up all of the gallons of water and
see them explode you know and uh I
actually shot his gun once the 357
Magnum it's quite a powerful weapon yeah
of course but but the problem with that
is it's is a really good stewardship
because ammunition is terribly expensive
these days and just to waste ammunition
for sport yeah you know makes you wonder
and then uh using uh guns or weapons to
kill animals
mhm feel sorry for the poor animals you
know yeah and then you know using uh a
gun for a deterrent there's always a
danger that you'll use it not only for a
deterrent but the shoot somebody yeah so
I've never owned a gun um I know that U
that up at the property that we bought
for secret unsealed we have lots of wild
pigs and they can be pretty dangerous
yes and so um you know a couple of our
people have uh purchased a gun to just
to protect themselves from the swine up
there from the wild board
yeah I know that is true it is
interesting you know like you said there
is it's not a sin it's not necessarily a
tool that everybody should have but if
there's a need and is that actual Danger
from a wild animal something like that
is Justified you know in that situation
of defense for from that aspect But
ultimately I think that for the most
part uh unless you live in a property or
in a place where there is wild animals
that can be harmful you know and that
can be um you know dangerous to your
family to yourself uh it really comes to
the fact of would Jesus really have a
gun you know to to protect yourself or
to like you said just go kill animals
just for sport I don't find that and
financially as you mentioned I remember
the yeah ammunition is super expensive
and it's a lot of money every I remember
a friend who was a neighbor had a a
couple of rifles that kind of thing and
he would tell me yeah each each bullet
was like a150 or something like that so
imagine you're throwing you know hundred
dollars every time he goes plays I mean
so it's it's it's probably not good
stewardship you know if if for example I
was threatened with somebody who comes
to steal yeah I'd rather have him steal
and uh and charge the insurance company
than to risk shooting him yeah of course
you know I I I don't think that I could
ever shoot and kill anyone yeah no so
you know because we are to preserve life
we're not to eliminate life absolutely
and and Christ even said you know those
that you know use the sword you know in
that way will perish By The Sword as
well so it it's important to understand
that you we have to be careful not to do
that I mean he even asked Peter to put
away his sword you know not to do harm
to human beings yeah Christians are held
to a higher standard you know the the
country has a mil military it has police
you know and they do use their weapons
to kill absolutely uh but we're talking
about Christians we have a different way
of thinking yeah uh than than the you
know the police and you know who who
preserve the the order of society amen
so I hope that this answers the
questions to our friend uh I pray that
he can continue to grow in Christ and uh
find the answers you know and and and
discuss these answers uh with the Lord
in prayer let's go to the next question
this is from Mark and this question is
regards to the
following
um now what uh was the transf there was
the Transfiguration of Jesus Christ
performed on the Sabbath
day so that's the first question I
suppose uh also was the wall of Jericho
destroyed on the Sabbath day seeing that
the Bible mentions the seventh day so
he's asking that the Transfiguration of
Jesus Christ was performed on the
Sabbath day and was the wall of Jericho
destroy on the Sabbath
day uh interesting things I know that
the Jericho they were to walk around the
city for seven days and in the seventh
day of the walking and around circling
around the the city they were to Circle
seven times and you know then
Shout with the S of the trumpet and the
Wolves will come down now it doesn't say
and I know this is a question that I I
found myself in the past but there's not
a definite answer as to the day of the
week uh it doesn't say the Sabbath day
it doesn't not say anywhere that they
started on Sunday and they finish on
Sabbath uh it's a conjunction I suppose
than anything but is not really
biblically uh described nor the spirit
prophecy speaks of that so I don't know
I I think this is something that we
probably have to answer the Lord has to
give us the answer in
heaven it was in cesaria Philippi that
Peter made his confession that Jesus was
the Messiah the Son of God MH and then
from there uh they they went South and
they ended up probably at Mount tabore
which is 1,800 uh plus feet above sea
level
and uh that's where the Transfiguration
most likely took place um Matthew says
that it was six days after six days
Jesus Took Peter James and John his
brother LED them up on a high mountain
by themselves that's Matthew 17 and
verse U verse one uh Luke has a little
differently and it might be that one is
using inclusive Reckoning and the other
is using strict Reckoning yeah uh but u
in uh Luke chapter 9 and verse 28 says
now it came to pass about 8 days after
these things that he took Peter John and
James and went went up on the mountain
to pray uh so you know if if he began on
a
Monday well then uh the the
Transfiguration would have been Sunday
or Monday depending on which gospel you
read yeah uh so there's no evidence
whatsoever that the Transfiguration took
place on the Sabbath yeah and another
thing that we find it and I I will be
inclined if I could answer this way
again it's not definite but right after
the Transfiguration I mean he came down
the mountain now we could say maybe that
was you know uh the next day as may he
spent the night in the mountain we're
not sure but we know from the next day
that the there were scribes who were
meeting with the disciples they because
they couldn't you know um re uh release
that human uh demon possessed boy and so
because of the healing we know that they
came to Jesus seeking or the father of
this young man came to Jesus to seek
healing for his son Jesus was in the
Mount of transfiguration his disciples
could not release that young boy from
the demon possession and a big multitude
gathered together the scrb were dis you
know discussing with the with the
disciples arguing about you know Jesus
not being the true Messiah he not been a
prophet of God and they the disciples
feeling like they were a failure and and
they felt hurt uh for not you know in
their in their in their pride that they
could not have the power to overcome and
so they started arguing discussing when
Jesus arrives right down coming down
from the mountain so um that day we know
I mean because of that multitude of
people because of what's going on it
really would not be a Sabbath day you
know it would not have been a Sabbath
day that they would wa waiting at the
foot of the mountain to seek for Jesus
you know especially the multitude and
these people so this is where again is
not 100% but definitely that day does
not seem to to fit into the description
of a Sabbath day for the Jewish uh
people and so uh to me that also sort of
makes it very hard to believe that Jesus
went there on the Sabbath day
specifically to mount uh of
transcreation and so I would say that
it's probably not the case if I was the
important thing is that he was
transfigured of course the lesson is
that exactly which day it happened uh
you know that that's uh not the not the
central thought exactly that uh the text
wants to get across exactly and so um do
we have one time for one more question
Pastor you think I think well we have
about three minutes left let's give it a
whirl let see all right let's try to get
this last question in greetings in the
gretings in the name of the Lord and
Jesus was Christ I am gring from the
beautiful cariban island of San Lucia
recently there have been a lot of
conversations concerning UFOs which have
been grabbed the attention of the United
States Congress to the point that
hearings are now being held in the
subject as a Bible believer and a 7-Day
Adventist I know that there are other
worlds out there which are unfallen by
the idea that there are military
spacecrafts from other worlds just
cannot be believed by me so my question
is how do we as Bible Believers address
such an issue and is this not an attack
on what the Bible teaches concerning
extraterrestrial phenomena
what do you think
Pastor well
um nobody knows exactly what the UFOs
are uh you know there's conjecture that
they might be Advanced military weapons
of China or Russia or even the United
States uh the speculation that it might
be inhabitants of other worlds believe
me God would not set inhabitants from
other worlds to scare Earthlings yes uh
you know and uh and so people who are
secular who don't have the biblical
worldview mhm they might say oh there's
life out there in the universe but for
them those planets are just like ours
you know they come to threaten us they
come to destroy us're in sin and of
course there's Hollywood movies that uh
enhance this uh this scenario you know
yeah uh all kinds of movies that that
say you know we're going to be invaded
Independence Day and so on yeah um but
the Bible makes it clear in the spirit
of Prophecy primarily the spirit of
Prophecy that the other worlds have
never fallen into sin MH they're not
coming here to scare us they're not
coming here to destroy us or to harass
us they're up there watching what's
happening in this world but they're not
actually coming uh to to invade us and
to destroy the planet and to make our
life miserable maybe the enemy can you
know I mean this Bible speaks of in the
the last days there will be all matter
of deceiving wonders you know and and
the enemy if he wants to take people
into fear into a attitude of you know
believing in a extraterrestrial power
entity I mean if I don't know he might
do that maybe it's you know a power of
him but ultimately as you mentioned
Pastor I believe that uh you know we
have to stand clear with the word of God
a spirit prophecy in regards to this you
know the enemy is not going to um be a
foreign EXT special power is the powers
that are operating in darkness using
human beings to uh intimidate or taking
us away from the truth from the word of
God and Satan V is going to do
everything possible yeah uh to
counterfeit the second coming of Christ
absolutely and uh is it just possible
that he's going to show up on some
unidentified flying object I'm not
saying it's going to be that way yeah
but you know with everybody believing in
it yeah uh who knows yeah who knows well
it is it this is it for today we thank
you once again for allowing us to come
to you may God bless you look forward to
spending time with you again in the
future blessings to
[Music]
you